It almost goes without saying that the inner
workings of the SCP Foundation are kept secret
from the general population.
Your average Joe doesn’t need or want to
know about the terrifying entities and bizarre
experiments happening behind the closed doors
of the various Foundation research sites.
But there are some secrets of the SCP Foundation
that even its own staff know very little about.
One such mystery is the highly classified
and immensely powerful O5-Council, or Overwatch
Council, that oversees everything that goes
on within the SCP Foundation.
They are considered the highest authority
within the organization, but very little is
known about them.
In fact, according to one official report
in the SCP Foundation archives, the O5 Council
does not exist at all.
Stick with me, here.
There are decades of reports concerning the
Council, there is a wealth of historical evidence
pointing to their existence and influence,
but they do not definitely exist.
At least, they don’t right now.
Take a deep breath, try and untangle the knots
we just tied in your brain, sit back and listen.
This is the story of SCP-001, the O5 Council
itself.
In 1965, SCP Foundation Administrator William
Cohen was preparing to leave his position.
To prepare his successor, H.V.
Oleander, Administrator Cohen drafted a series
of letters intended to pass on important,
and highly guarded knowledge, to the man who
would take his place.
In the letter, Administrator Cohen explained
that he was retiring early for a specific
reason, writing, “A tar clings to my mind,
sticking to every neuron and slowing my every
thought.
In truth, I am unwell.”
Cohen’s decline had begun eight years prior,
in late 1957 after the launch of Soviet space
probe Sputnik-1 into the Earth’s orbit.
The Foundation’s interest had been drawn
to the probe after a foreign signal had been
detected trying to communicate with it.
Not a signal from a foreign nation, mind you,
but something from much further away, and
likely something that was not human.
Whatever it was, it was trying to communicate,
and it was getting closer.
On January 4, 1958, the signal stopped and
an unidentified object arrived on Earth.
Cohen was summoned to the war room at Site-00,
much to his surprise.
It was highly unusual for guests to be invited
to the Site.
There, they worked together to identify the
nature of the situation with Sputnik, until
a single burst of gamma radiation was detected
and Sputnik’s orbit began to decay.
The Council panicked, calling heads of state
and calling for as many resources as possible.
They had worked themselves into a frenzy and
were planning to shoot down the first space
probe in Earth’s history.
Eventually, the decision was placed in Cohen’s
hands: let the probe land on its own, or shoot
it down?
Overwhelmed by the Council’s intensity,
Cohen told them to do what they thought was
best.
They shot it down.
He did not want to, but he crumbled under
the pressure.
There were so many of them and only one of
him, and they seemed so certain in their decision.
This was the first decision in his career
that Cohen regretted, and it was presumably
followed by many more.
He continued in his letter, saying, “And
now what credibility do I have left to disagree
with them?
I am but a mouthpiece.
A sad, old puppet tangled up and caught in
the very strings used to make him dance.”
Cohen wrote his letter to his successor with
one warning: “Just as I have shown you vulnerability
here in the hopes I might gain your trust,
please consider asking the same from those
who would insist you trust them.”
In March of 1958, following the incident with
Sputnik, the O5 Council collectively submitted
a notice to the Foundation’s Leadership
Committee.
They stated simply: “The Individual you
call your administrator has proven insufficient.
We solicit you to make your preparations and
nominate another.”
No individual members of the Council wrote
in, but rather submitted their thoughts as
a collective, as if thinking together as one
single mind.
The language used was also curious, saying
“Your Administrator,” rather than “Our
Administrator.”
The O5 Council seemed to think of itself as
something separate from the SCP Foundation,
its own entity rather than simply a powerful
arm or leader of the organization itself.
On June 11, 1962, another notice was sent
out.
It read, “Foundation, a life lived in service
of the greater good is invalidated if death
does not also serve.”
On November 11, 1965, a third notice was sent
out, this time to all Foundation staff: “Please
join us in remembering the life and career
of Administrator William Cohen.
The only constant is change.
Because of this, the erosion of his skills,
abilities, knowledge, and confidence was inevitable.”
Administrator H.V.
Oleander took over the position for many years
after Cohen’s demise.
In 1988, he prepared to step down and drafted
a letter to his successor, Natalia Elllingbrooke.
Like Cohen before him, Oleander tried his
best to explain where he went wrong, in the
hope that she might do better.
Oleander began the letter, “I used to have
such an ego.
This job, this life, and the burdens that
surround it crush and squeeze you until all
you have left is what they force you to keep.
My mind and my soul feel as though they've
been contorted into the shape of someone I
no longer recognize.
My predecessor, may he rest in peace, described
his years as if he were trapped behind smoky
glass and made to watch a foggy world pass
him by.
Like some sort of voyeur.
I, too, feel imprisoned but I realize that
it was never a looking glass.
It is a mirror.”
The events detailed in the letter began in
November of 1985, after a powerful storm had
ripped through New England and caused severe
damage to Site-31’s power grid.
During the power outage, a multi-stage containment
breach occurred and an unnamed infovore escaped
from the facility.
The entity was lost until March of 1986, when
it was detected in a government facility in
Warsaw, Poland.
Determined to make up for his previous failure,
Oleander organized a mission to bring the
entity back into custody.
His team tracked it down and was prepared
to apprehend the entity’s host when the
O5 Council expressed concern that this behavior
might cause an international incident and
intervened.
The Council made the decision to reach out
to local and international governments in
Poland, allowing the entity to escape to Pripyat,
Ukraine.
Oleander and the Council went head to head
on this, pushing and pulling and becoming
increasingly aggressive on either side.
Oleander could not make up his mind about
what to do: listen to the Council, or trust
his own gut?
On April 26, 1986, his indecision resulted
in a nuclear disaster in Soviet territory.
Not only that, but the entity still evaded
containment.
The mission was a complete failure.
The O5 Council submitted a report on the incident,
stating: “We recommended that the healing
process commence by first assigning blame.
The collective good would be served by purging
liability.”
And “WE WOULD HAVE HELPED.
ANYONE WOULD HAVE HELPED.
WHY DENY IT??”
By now, the pattern has probably become clear
to you.
The Administrator and the Council fall into
conflict over a difficult decision.
Something goes horribly wrong.
A new Administrator is chosen, the former
Administrator writes them a letter to prepare
them for the heavy demands of the job, and
the cycle begins again.
As you might expect, during those days of
her administration, Oleander’s replacement
Natalie Ellingbrooke sat down to write a letter
of warning to one Michelle Wilkes, who was
chosen to replace her.
Ellingbrooke began her letter, “As you've
likely surmised from our few meetings, I walk
with a pronounced limp and favor my left leg.
How I came to be like this isn't especially
interesting but what it did to me might be
of interest to a person in your position.
Any man or woman changes when they are exposed
to pain.
Simply put, it has to go somewhere.
If you hold it all within yourself, it may
stay contained but it will surely destroy
you when you've had your fill.
It festers in all the spaces you let it occupy,
warping and scarring what used to be healthy,
happy tissue sat beneath.
Some people have hobbies, but me?
I've always just had my work.
I've been ringside for so much pain in my
time with the Foundation.
My predecessor left me a note, much like I
am leaving you, and in it he warned me of
the tremendous duty and guilt he hid in order
to do his job.
Although the slings and arrows of outrageous
fortune stung him quite keenly, I assure you
I have suffered every bit his equal.
The breach at the Olympics in '94, losing
control of Site-248 in '96.
Botched facility transfer of Hong Kong in
'97.
Bombings in Bali in '02.
The dispute with ORIA in the Congo in '03.
The GOC Ultimatum in '04.”
She continued, “Although I have weathered
much, my tenure is up not with the sort of
precipitating bang that ousted Oleander, but
rather the quiet whimper of stepping away
from a battle I no longer wish to fight.
I am tired of the Council calling a meeting
on every decision I try to make and I am tired
of calling one on every decision they try
to make without me.
I guess that reasoning is another tribute
to the selfish life I have led.
My ideal way to say goodbye would have been
to simply stop coming in.
My desk would have sat empty, emails unread,
until one day a courier showed up with my
keys and badge.
But even here, at the end of my career, the
O5 Council insists on refusing to let me be
myself.
So tomorrow I will play the part of a dutiful
officer resigning her post and walk away from
Site-00 with my head held high and those overbearing
bastards in the rear-view mirror.
I pray that your head will never be so bowed
as mine has.”
Administrator Wilkes took her predecessor’s
words to heart and began her tenure with a
new proposal for Project TETHYS.
The project would include modifications to
the Three Gorges Dam facility at the Yangtze
River, as part of a containment procedure
for Entity 2005-C-ET-011.
The Council refused to approve her proposal.
Administrator Wilkes insisted that they provide
a list of concerns, explaining what their
issues with her proposal were.
The two argued back and forth over the necessity
of a meeting until the Council submitted this
note to her: “We know how important it is
to get off on the right foot.
Although This Body respects you and the autonomy
which you command, We have also seen many
come and go.
You were chosen from your peers but they have
chosen many others in the past.
We remain unconvinced.
Before you, Ellingbrooke, who spent her whole
life pushing others aside so she could lead.
She left all others behind.
Trees with no roots do not hold to the ground.
Before her, Oleander, who wanted so much to
be seen as your Hero in white.
He could no longer live with himself once
his clothes were stained, but The Sin does
not define The Saint.
Before him, Cohen, who wanted nothing more
than to be the one who made the decisions.
He collapsed in on himself when there was
no easy victory.
No man is an island.
And a dozen more whose names We have subrogated.
You need Us.
You are not enough.”
Administrator Wilkes was offended by this
response and argued that the meeting was unnecessary.
She asked for the Council to trust her expertise
and the expertise of her employees.
They responded, “Your distinctiveness did
not arise from the ether; You are a synthesis
of available materials and experiences.
If needed, another could be synthesized.
We are needed.
We are necessary.
We synthesize.
You are not.
You cannot.
Become We or become They.
The choice is yours.”
Administrator Wilkes suddenly understood.
The Council was not a part of the Foundation,
they were something else entirely.
Though she couldn’t be completely sure what
they were, she knew one thing for certain:
they were not her friends.
She fired back at the Council’s threats:
“You cast your shadow over the future with
your threats and intimidation, certain we
would be nothing without you, but I am forced
to wonder who or what would you be without
us?
I stand with the countless thousands that
have died for our mission, the people that
have engineered our solutions, the people
that will build them, and the people that
will risk their lives in order to carry out
these procedures in the hope our mission might
one day be complete.
Without them, I know I would be nothing.
We are willing to take our chances without
you.
I am going to offer you the same choice you
gave me.
Become We or become They.”
Several days passed with no response, and
Administrator Wilkes made the most difficult
decision of her career: She suspended the
appointment of the O5 Council until a day
comes when it becomes necessary again.
Secure Area-00 has been set up around the
area containing SCP-001.
The area has been classified, designated Level
6 or Cosmic Secret.
The coordinates of this Secure Area are stored
in cranial implants placed in 15 carefully
selected Foundation leaders, including Ethics
Committee members and Site Directors.
These candidates can participate in voting
once a vote is called, but are to be kept
unaware of their status as voters unless it
becomes necessary.
If a supermajority votes to decrypt the contents
of these cranial implants, the location of
Secure Area-00 will be revealed to them.
If the security of these implants becomes
compromised, COGITA.aic will generate a new
protocol and a new list of candidates will
be selected.
The original candidates will have the encrypted
information deleted from their minds.
No one may access Secure Area-00 at any time
for any reason unless the aforementioned vote
takes place.
Operation protocols, defenses, building schematics,
and all other information about the Site have
been expunged from Foundation records.
Oh, what’s this?
A new Addendum has been unlocked!
This is for your eyes and ears only.
Yes, I’m talking to you.
Do not share this information with anyone
else.
A retinal scan has confirmed your identity
and the COGITO protocol has been executed.
You are receiving this Addendum because Administrator
Michelle Wilkes is dead, after nearly twenty
years of service.
Before her death, she prepared a statement
regarding the role of the Administrator at
the Foundation.
The Addendum contains a message from Administrator
Michelle Wilkes, to you, her designated successor.
Surprise, you have been chosen as the next
Administrator for The SCP Foundation.
You may be surprised, asking “Really, me?”
Yes, you.
You may not know it, but you were chosen quite
some time ago.
The cranial implant has been in place for
years.
Now it is ready to be activated.
Michelle Wilkes’s message is intended to
prepare you for the trials and tribulations
that lie ahead, and to encourage you to ask
yourself: what kind of leader will you be?
Are you willing to do whatever it takes to
perform this most solemn duty?
The following comes from the former Administrator
herself.
Listen carefully, and consider what she has
to say.
Your future at the Foundation, the fate of
your subordinates, and your very legacy, may
depend on it.
“Consider now, before fate takes away the
luxury of time, what type of person, co-worker,
and leader you want to be.
Each and every one of the Administrators before
me was challenged in terms both great and
small during their tenures, and I was no exception
to this pattern.
The office you occupy is not about the power
and influence you now command.
Nor is it even about the unfathomable responsibility
you must now shepherd.
It is instead about the character, integrity,
and vision with which you meet the test of
leadership and, should you prove worthy, surmount
it.
You and the people you will lead must be asked
to undertake tasks no person should ever be
asked to carry out.
Yet duty and the safety of all mankind demand
that you make this sacrifice.
For them.
For each other.
If your resolve should ever falter, know that
everyone you lead stands with you.
We are ready to follow you into the blackest
night if you let us believe in the promise
of dawn.
But should your resolve ever break, the Council
awaits.
They will invite you to Site-00 if you ask.
You need only surrender.
Best wishes, M. Wilkes.
Former Administrator.”
What, exactly, is the O5 Council?
That is a question not easily answered.
They are not flesh and blood, not individual
minds and feelings, but something else entirely.
They are a collective, something that thinks,
breathes, and votes together as one being.
They view the world as two things: We, and
They.
As you prepare to take on the role of Administrator,
keep in mind who you are.
Be strong, be brave, be resolute, and hold
on to your sense of right and wrong.
But if you ever should falter, if you decide
to stop being You and become We, there is
always Site-00.
Remember, even though they do not officially
exist: the Council awaits.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - The Gate Guardian”
and “SCP-001 - The Black Moon” for more
enigmatic SCP-001 proposals!